The Star Wars universe is vast and infinitely
rich in lore, with just about every minor
background character having their own book,
action figure, and fanfic page.
It can all get a bit overwhelming for the
average fan, which is why we've put together
this quick guide to some of the new Rogue
One characters with more meaning than you
realize.
Tivik
While you're toasting the destruction of the
Death Star, stop and pour out a 40 for poor
Tivik.
If you don't recognize the name, Tivik is
the Rebel informant who passes word to Cassian
Andor about Bodhi's secret message.
Andor repays Tivik by slaying him.
It's a surprisingly dark move for a member
of the heroic Rebel Alliance, which in previous
films had been painted as the white knights
of the galaxy.
Cassian's ruthless decision to slay Tivik
in order to ensure the secrecy of his mission
paints the Alliance in a far more morally
ambiguous light, and sets the tone for the
entire film by letting the audience know right
away that this isn't your parents' shiny,
happy Rebellion.
With both the plot and the tone of the movie
turning on Tivik, his one short scene holds
an unusual amount of meaning.
Weeteef Cyubee
This guy has very little backstory so far,
but Weeteef Cyubee's presence among Saw Gerrera's
Partisans speaks to the variety of the Empire's
misdeeds.
If this little trigger-happy piranha-looking
dude hates the Empire enough to fight, main,
and die on the side of the Rebels, then the
Empire might want to consider re-evaluating
its outreach policy.
Given what we know of the Ewoks' future role
in bringing down the Empire, it would seem
that the Empire's policies either discriminate
against or simply don't account for vertically
challenged species.
And that's not the only connection between
Weeteef and the Ewoks: Weeteef was played
by Warwick Davis, who also played Wicket in
Return of the Jedi.
(Cute Ewok sound)
Beezer Fortuna
Related to Jabba the Hutt's right-hand man
Bib Fortuna, Beezer is another member of the
Partisans.
The fate of Beezer, who was seen briefly at
Saw Gerrera's hideout on Jedha, is unclear,
but his connection to Bib Fortuna speaks to
Saw Gerrera's willingness to work with the
criminal underworld to bring down the Empire.
Too bad we didn't get to see the two Fortunas
settle their ideological differences — through
a desert dance-off!.
KX-Series Security Droid
The KX-Series Security Droid is a product
line of Arakyd Industries, a company whose
connection to the Galactic Empire runs deep.
The KX-Series clearly has some serious security
issues, which allowed Cassian Andor to reprogram
K-2SO to the good side.
"I'll be there for you.
The captain said I had to."
Despite this, though, Arakyd Industries remains
partnered with the Empire throughout the original
trilogy.
They're the folks responsible for the iconic
Viper probe droids that hunt down Luke Skywalker
and Han Solo on the ice planet Hoth in The
Empire Strikes Back.
Why would the Empire keep working with a company
which makes dangerously shoddy droids that
can be easily hacked, or taken out with one
shot?
Probably because Grand Moff Tarkin inadvertently
destroyed the evidence of their droids' vulnerabilities
when he blew up Scariff base.
Whoops!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!